on ne peut pas se résoudre à l'idée que
ce virus
jens attaqué et tué dans nos dans nos
établissements et les personnes les
personnes qui vivent donc la peur elle
est permanent permanente cetc il faut
vivre avec et nous nos établissements
doivent apprendre et donc appris à vivre
avec sur nos établissements qui
accueillent des personnes âgées fragiles
nous sommes confrontés à une difficulté
permanente un dilemme permanent entre
protéger les personnes qu'on accueille
empêcher le qu'ovide d'entrée de se
répandre lorsqu'il est entré ce dilemme
il est confronté à une autre une autre
volonté farouche des établissements
c'est de permettre aux personnes âgées
de vivre le mieux possible et ça fait
pour vivre le mieux possible
il faut évidemment pouvoir avoir des
relations avec ses proches et avec et
avec sa famille donc c'est ce qui est
extrêmement compliqué aujourd'hui à
gérer dans nos établissements